what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and wow doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness was an
insane movie and if you're here right
now you want to know what's up with
those post-credits scenes and i have to
tell you it is really really exciting
because we have a new character who
seems to be taking over the role of
christine palmer because in the comics
at least she is dr strange's lover and
wife actually so we'll go over
everything that you need to know about
her in this video and also talk about
how avengers secret wars is being set up
for the mcu and they did that big time
here in this post credit scene and in
the actual film and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe we
cover marvel content daily and we'll be
covering the obi-wan series and some dc
movies coming up as well like black adam
now obviously i have to issue a spoiler
warning if you have not seen doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness yet
and you are trying to avoid spoilers you
should click away now because we're
about to dive into them now to know the
first post credit scene you of course
have to know what happened at the end of
doctor strange everything was over and
done everything kind of seemed fine
doctor strange was walking down the
street then all of a sudden he started
to experience agonizing pain and he fell
to the floor and this is where his third
eye is revealed now we saw that the
darkest doctor strange variant who was
actively using the dark hold had a third
eye as well this was because he was
corrupted by the darkhold then our
doctor strange defeated him and he went
on to use the dark cold and to dreamwalk
and now it seems like he has been
corrupted by it as well but seeing as
how our doctor strange appears to be
very different than the others i don't
think that this is going to be a huge
problem then we go to our post credit
scene where doctor strange actually
seemingly is fine he is walking down the
street no third eye no agonizing pain
but then a person comes up behind him
and she calls out to him doctor strange
he turns around looks very confused and
says can i help you she then says you
caused an incursion and we're gonna fix
it she then summons a magical blade and
cuts a rift in their reality to the dark
dimension the same dark dimension that
we saw in the first doctor strange film
where dormammu was she looks into the
dark dimension turns back to doctor
strange and says unless you're afraid in
which doctor strange takes a scarf
throws it over the back of his neck and
it turns into his cloak and entire
doctor strange outfit and he says not in
the least as we see his third eye open
and the two of them jump in now like i
said it doesn't really seem like the
third eye corruption is going to be a
problem for our doctor strange as we see
here doctor strange is completely fine
and he seems to actually be using the
third eye to his advantage now the third
eye in the comics his mystic eye is
actually the eye of agamotto not a
physical eye that he opens from his
forehead so they definitely changed this
up a little bit in the mcu giving it a
little bit of a twist but keep in mind
that the darkhold in every reality has
been destroyed by the scarlet witch so
the risk of him using it and becoming
more corrupt and evil isn't really that
high and he probably realizes this and
figures out a way to make it work to his
advantage now this person is clea i'm
sorry to all the people who thought that
it was psylocke i admit yes that blade
does look like psylocke's but this is
not the x-men psyluck this is clia
doctor strange's romantic interest in
the comics and eventually his wife and
the sorcerer supreme of the dark
dimension and to top it all off she is
actually the niece of dormammu when
khalia was born her mother was actually
banished from the dimension that they
were at so she grew up not knowing who
her mother was but her father served her
mama so she grew up worshiping dormammu
in the dark dimension now eventually
dormammu would threaten earth and the
ancient one sends doctor strange to the
dark dimension to defeat dormammu this
is where clia notices him and follows
him around and she eventually ends up
helping him and betraying dormammu now
their story is pretty long and pretty
complicated but eventually clia does
come to earth in which she trains under
doctor strange however she does
eventually return to the dark dimension
where she rules over it as sorcerer
supreme this does put a strain on the
relationship between her and doctor
strange but the two of them actually get
mystically married check this out they
couldn't actually legally get married
because she is actually from another
dimension not a citizen of earth so they
wore magical rings that were actually
only one and were therefore mystically
connected for all of eternity so as you
can see this is a pretty huge character
that has been introduced to the mcu here
and plus not to mention it's charlize
theron who is absolutely fantastic but
one of the big things that this
post-credit scene sets up as well as the
actual movie sets up is secret wars
specifically a story where incursion
occurs now we learned what incursion was
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and it's pretty much exactly
what happens in the comics and this
eventually leads to the multiverse
essentially collapsing incursion occurs
and universes start to combine with each
other and some start to collapse and i
think that this is where the mcu is
heading eventually the multiverse itself
will be destroyed and only one universe
is going to be left and from here we
will see a bunch of different variants
interacting with each other we'll have a
bunch of different variants of thor loki
iron man doctor strange the scarlet
witch spider-man then they'll go up
against villains like doctor doom kang
and whoever else the mcu wants to
introduce before then and at that point
in time we'll have the fantastic four
and the x-men and the mcu as well so
this really is going to be a huge huge
movie when they finally do it way bigger
than avengers infinity war and end game
if you can even believe that but again
incursion is a big part of that because
incursion is what leads to the
destruction of universes and the
multiverse and we have this big
illuminati scene here with mr fantastic
john krasinski as mr fantastic reed
richards explaining the threat of
incursion which was the whole reason
that doctor strange was being judged by
the illuminati so it really does look
like secret wars tends to be the huge
story that marvel studios is eventually
going to lead up to which is really
exciting because we're going to get some
pretty amazing characters and their
variants including god emperor doom and
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness we had the introduction of the
x-men and the fantastic four so
hopefully the true main mcu earth 616
x-men and fantastic four are coming soon
now as far as that second post-credit
scene goes we go back to pizza papa
played by bruce campbell during the
movie america chavez goes up to a stand
and gets some pizza balls from him she
thinks they're free because she explains
to doctor strange that food in most
universes is free and it's weird that
his universe makes you pay for food
however she is actually wrong in this
universe you still have to pay for food
so pizza papa wants his money dr strain
casts a spell on him that makes him
start to punch himself in the face and
beat himself up he explains that the
spell will eventually wear out and
america chavez says in like three hours
and he explains well no kind of in like
three weeks so here we are three weeks
later and he finally stops hitting
himself he looks at his hand as it's now
not hitting him laughs hysterically
looks directly into the camera and yells
it's over now obviously this is a little
bit of a pun here a little bit of a joke
he's obviously referring to it's over as
in his hand is no longer hitting him the
spell is over but he's also making a
joke that the movie's over this is the
last post-credits scene and it's done
and honestly it was fine it was a funny
scene but i was hoping for more i was
hoping for another big post-credits
scene here perhaps a deadpool setup
maybe an x-men or fantastic four set up
where we see john krasinski as the
actual earth-616 reed richards or the
baxter building being built but hey i'm
really excited for the future of marvel
studios and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness proved that marvel
can go in a different direction than
they normally do and absolutely crush it
but let me know what you thought about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness in the comments down below did
you enjoy it or did you not like it let
me know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
for more marvel news you can follow me
on instagram and twitter for live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof